Washington is panicking over the
president's latest effort to create a
rational foreign policy but the
Ukrainian Pietschmann effort judges for
it you've heard endlessly on cable news
it's unprecedented that the president
would seek political gain from a
conversation with the foreign leader
well turns out it's happened before back
in 2000 we can report President Bill
Clinton had a conversation with Tony
Blair of the UK and asked him directly
to intercede in a dispute between
British Airways and two American
carriers the president at the time was
much more direct than president Trump
was in his conversation with the
Ukrainian leader this is Bill Clinton
back then I'm quoting in a political
season it would be big over here to get
this open sore resolved if you could
have somebody take a look at it he asked
Tony Lee responded that he would now is
this a big deal not really
is it naked Lee political is it an
effort to use a foreign country to
influence the outcome of an election in
a presidential year well yes it is
obviously
incidentally didn't take long for us to
find that transcript we only had to dig
through old Clinton transcripts about 15
minutes they're all capped they're all
in line by the way they're probably a
lot more examples and if we find them
we'll bring them to you but the point is
anyone commenting on this anyone staring
at the screen and her countless people
who fit this description and tell you
this has never happened before it's
outrageous none of them took the time to
check because whenever they're telling
you that something is without precedent
you can be certain it happens every day
here